bord schengen est un dossier fondamental
de la construction européenne d'ailleurs
et c'est vrai qu'il ne convient pas le
remettre en cause
globalement parce que la libre
circulation entre les différents pays de
l'espace schengen est une des grande
plus value de l'union européenne au fil
des années on s'en rend pas comblé
jeunes se rendent pas compte mais quand
on est quinquagénaire comme moi et qu'on
a dû patienter à des frontières chaque
fois et montrer cette partie pour passer
d'un pays à l'autre simplement pour
aller en vacances ou en revenir
bah c'était quand même une époque
pénible c'est un des grands acquis qui
peut être aménagée en fonction des crise
que l'on vit ça je peux comprendre qu'on
aura l'occasion certainement leur parler
or dans le courant du débat mais de fait
jouer avec schengen c'est jouer avec le
feu